Searchlight Pictures presents The Roses, only in theaters August 29th. From the director of Meet the Parents and the writer of Poor Things, comes The Roses, starring Academy Award winner Olivia Coleman, Academy Award nominee, Benedict Cumberbatch, Andy Samburg, Kate McKinnon, and Allison Janney. A hilarious new comedy filled with drama, excitement, and a little bit of hatred, proving that marriage isn't always a bed of roses. See The Roses Only in Theater's August 29th. Get tickets now.
Searchlight Pictures 呈献《The Roses》，8月29日仅在影院上映。本片由《拜见岳父大人》导演与《可怜的东西》编剧联袂打造，奥斯卡奖得主奥利维娅·科尔曼、奥斯卡奖提名者本尼迪克特·康伯巴奇、安迪·萨姆伯格、凯特·麦金农以及艾莉森·珍妮主演。这是一部充满戏剧性、刺激感和一丝恨意的爆笑全新喜剧，证明了婚姻并不总是一帆风顺。《The Roses》8月29日仅在影院上映，立即购票。
I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. Hello. Hi.
我是珍娜·费舍，我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在，我们专门为你带来了终极的《办公室》爱好者播客。每周，我们将通过独家采访、幕后细节和大量闺蜜故事，更深入地探索《办公室》的世界。我们是 Office Ladies 6.0。你好。嗨。
Welcome back to Office Lady. 86.0. Angela, are you ready for some jump scares? Maybe some airy music and a really scary villain. Why would I be ready for any of that? I don't know, but you better get ready because today we're breaking down the webisode, the third floor, which is all about Ryan making a horror movie. Well, Jenna, I know you're very excited for today's episode. You love a good horror movie. Love. I hate them. Mm-hmm. But I want to tell you, I'm just thankful that there are no zombies in this one because I really hate zombies. I love zombies. Give me all the zombies. I mean, Ryan tried to have zombies. We'll get to it. Yeah, I know. I got excited. This is one thing you and I do have in common, though. What do we have in
欢迎回到 Office Ladies 6.0。安吉拉，你准备好迎接一些惊吓了吗？可能还有一些空灵的音乐和一个非常可怕的恶棍。我为什么要做这种准备？我不知道，但你最好准备好，因为今天我们要剖析网络剧集《三楼》，这集讲的全是瑞恩拍恐怖片的故事。好吧，珍娜，我知道你对今天的节目非常兴奋。你很喜欢恐怖片。喜欢。我讨厌它们。嗯哼。但我想告诉你，我只是庆幸这里面没有僵尸，因为我真的很讨厌僵尸。我超爱僵尸。把所有僵尸都给我。我是说，瑞恩试过搞僵尸。我们待会儿会聊到。对，我知道。我很激动。不过这是你和我共同的一个共同点。我们有什么
common? Well, I don't know if we should talk about it, but we both had a really strong reaction to the season of The Last of Us. You know, Josh had me watch it. He wanted me to watch it. I know. How did Josh get you to even start watching this? You watched the whole thing. first season. Yes. And then you got hooked. I was very excited because this is our first zombie crossover moment. Yeah, I mean, I love Pedro. Pedro Pascal. Well, we all love Pedro Pascal, which is why this season was so very upsetting to us because we didn't play the video game, everybody. Jen and I didn't know. We didn't know what was going to happen. And after it happened, I was so upset. Spoiler, if you, okay, if you don't know the video game and if you haven't,
共同点？好吧，我不知道我们该不该聊这个，但我们俩对《最后生还者》这一季的反应都非常强烈。你知道的，乔希让我看它。他想让我看。我我知道。乔希是怎么让你开始看这个的？你看了整整第一季。对。然后你就迷上了。我非常兴奋，因为这是我们的第一次僵尸跨界时刻。对，我是说，我喜欢佩德罗。佩德罗·帕斯卡。好吧，我们都喜欢佩德罗·帕斯卡，这就是为什么这一季让我们如此沮丧，因为我们没玩过这款游戏，各位。珍娜和我根本不知道。我们不知道会发生什么。事情发生后，我太沮丧了。剧透一下，如果你，好吧，如果你不知道这款游戏，而且你还没有，
watched this show yet. Just like... Fast forward, maybe. Fast forward, because I actually need to talk about this. And I know we're a little late to talking about it, because everyone expressed this same outrage about two months ago. But truly, if you haven't played the video game and you haven't seen season two, just fast forward about 50 seconds from now. Yes. Guys, Pedro Pascal's character has the most gruesome death in episode two, in episode two. I kept waiting. I was like, Wait, what? Shirley, oh, here she comes. She's going to come rescue him.
还没看过这部剧。那就...快进吧，也许吧。快进，因为我真的需要聊聊这个。我知道我们聊这个有点晚了，因为大家在大约两个月前就表达过同样的愤怒。但说实话，如果你没玩过游戏，也没看过第二季，那就从现在开始快进大约50秒吧。对。伙计们，佩德罗·帕斯卡饰演的角色在第二集里迎来了最惨烈的死亡，在第二集里。我一直在等。我在想：等等，什么？真的假的，哦，她来了。她要来救他了。
No, no, no. And here's the thing. I'm not watching it anymore. I can't watch it anymore. He was my guy. You broke my heart. Why would I keep going out with a guy who broke my heart like that? Like, the show is a man who I was in love with, and he fucking trampled on my heart.
不，不，不。事情是这样的。我再也不看了。我没法再看了。他可是我的男神。你伤了我的心。我怎么能继续和一个这样伤我心的男人在一起呢？这部剧就像是一个我曾深爱着的男人，而他他妈的狠狠践踏了我的心。
I can't go back to him. I can't go back to him. It was too much for me. And I sent a text to our group thread where I was like, what is? And I googled. I was like, what am I? You're three like angry messages, like angry long messages about what the hell just happened here. Yeah, we both were pretty bummed about that. Josh is still watching. So he has continued without me. I was like, I can't. I was like, babe, here's the thing. You can't ask me. As someone who hates zombies, I hate zombies. Yep. You can't ask me to watch a zombie show with the one thing that kept me watching it is gone. Yes. That was the only reason I was there.
我没法回到他身边。我没法回到他身边。这对我来说太过了。我在我们的群聊里发了一条信息，我说：这是什么？我谷歌了一下。我说：我到底是什么？你连发了三条愤怒的信息，全是愤怒的长篇大论，质问这到底是怎么回事。对，我们俩当时都挺沮丧的。乔希还在看。所以他抛下我继续看了。我说：我受不了。我说：宝贝，事情是这样的。你不能要求我——作为一个讨厌僵尸的人，我讨厌僵尸——没错，你不能要求我去看一部僵尸剧，而唯一让我坚持看下去的东西却没了。对。那是我看这部剧的唯一原因。
Okay, it wasn't the only reason I was there, but I am so distraught that I have not been able to keep watching it. I think I might. I think I will get over this hurt. But listen to me, everybody, we all know. I was trying to explain it to Lee because Lee doesn't watch it with me. He's like, I don't get, like, just this one person died. I'm like, babe, babe, it's Pedro Pascal, okay?
好吧，这其实不是我唯一的看点，但我难过得简直无法继续看下去了。我想我可能会。我想我会熬过这种心痛的。但是听我说，各位，我们都知道。我试图向李解释，因为李不跟我一起看。他说：我不明白，不就是死了一个人嘛。我说：宝贝，宝贝，那是佩德罗·帕斯卡，好吗？
He is like, I tried to come up with, like, an analogy. I was like, he is, remember what Meg Ryan was to like an 80s romantic comedy movie? Just like an utter delight from the moment she's on screen until the end. Yeah. Like, just makes you happy watching her. That is the feeling I get when I watch Pedro Pascal in anything. Just a delight. I'm happier now. You know what it is for me? I'm invested. Whatever he's in, I'm so invested. I still really,
他就好像，我试着想出一个类比。我说：他就像，还记得梅格·瑞恩对于80年代浪漫喜剧电影意味着什么吗？从她出场的那一刻到结束，简直就是纯粹的快乐源泉。对。就像，看着她就会让你感到开心。每当我看到佩德罗·帕斯卡演任何角色时，我都会有这种感觉。简直就是一种享受。我现在更开心了。你知道对我来说这意味着什么吗？我投入进去了。无论他演什么，我都全身心投入。我依然非常、
really need you to see his Ark in Game of Thrones. I really need you to get to Dorn. I am so sorry. I saw a red carpet interview with him where someone said, will you ever have such a brutal death as you had in Game of Thrones that will upset fans? And he said, yes, I think there will be because he knew what was going to happen in The Last of Us. I still need you to see him in Game of Thrones. Sam. Yeah, I need you to watch that episode at least. I don't want to just tune in to see him die. You need to see the minute he comes on screen, his presence, it's so different from the other characters you've seen him play. I need you to see him.
非常需要你去看看他在《权力的游戏》里的故事线。我真的很需要你去看看多恩。非常抱歉。我看到过一个关于他的红毯采访，有人问他：你会不会也迎来像在《权力的游戏》里那样惨烈的死法，让粉丝们心碎？他说：会，我觉得会有，因为他当时就知道《最后生还者》里会发生什么。我还是需要你在《权力的游戏》里看看他。山姆。对，我需要你至少看那一集。我可不想只为了看他死而去看。你需要看看他一出场的那一分钟，他的气场，跟他以前演过的其他角色太不一样了。我需要你去看看。
My introduction to him was in Game of Thrones. Okay, my introduction to him was in Narcos. Oh, he's great in Narcos. Okay, I will watch Game of Thrones for Pedro Pascal, like done. I will do it. What season is he? Like, how far in? I mean, could she just pick up with that season, Sam?
我认识他是通过《权力的游戏》。好吧，我认识他是通过《毒枭》。哦，他在《毒枭》里演得真棒。好吧，为了佩德罗·帕斯卡，我会去看《权力的游戏》，一言为定。我这就去看。他是从第几季开始的？剧情推进到哪了？我是说，她难道不能直接从那一季开始看吗，山姆？
She doesn't have to like watch all the way too when they have the Dorn brothers, sisters on. So he first appears in season four, episode one. Oh, my God. Cassie. You guys. I say, just go there. Don't. I got pretty far in the Game of Thrones when I committed to watching it.
她不一定非要一直看到多恩家族的兄弟姐妹们登场的那一季。所以他第一次出场是在第四季第一集。天哪。凯西。你们这群人。我说，直接去那一季吧。别。我当年下定决心看《权力的游戏》时，其实已经看了挺远的了。
Like, I'm pretty sure. I've told you, like, when is that red lady on that extra island? Yeah. Isn't that, like, in season three or something? No, no, you're not talking about the red wedding. You're talking about the red lady who had sex with the black smoke. Oh, okay. Yeah, her.
差不多。我跟你说过，就是那个红袍女在哪个外岛上的时候？对。那是不是大概在第三季左右？不，不，你说的不是血色婚礼。你说的是那个跟黑色烟雾发生关系的红袍女。哦，好吧。对，就是她。
Yeah. I don't know what season that is, but that was around where it lost me. I would pick up. I would start season three. I would watch season three and then treat yourself with a first episode of season four at the end. Have you seen the Red Wedding episode? I don't know what happens in a Red Wedding. Oh, you would know.
对。我不知道那是第几季，但差不多就是在那里我失去了兴趣。我会从。我会从第三季开始看。我会看第三季，然后在最后用第四季的第一集犒劳一下自己。你看过血色婚礼那一集吗？我不知道血色婚礼里发生了什么。哦，那你肯定知道。
Never mind. Never mind. That's a great episode. Okay. Okay. Well, we might have to make a list for her. Well, you know what? We should probably take a break because when we come back, we are going to break down the third floor.
算了。算了。那一集太棒了。好吧。好吧。那我们可能得给她列个清单了。好吧，你知道吗？我们大概该休息一下了，因为等我们回来后，我们要剖析《三楼》。
And Jenna, as our resident horror movie expert, you're going to give us your assessment of Ryan's attempt at this genre. I will. I will. I tried to give it my best critique. Okay. But that's not all everybody. I gave Angela an assignment that I'm so excited about. I asked her to watch the first 24 minutes and 30 seconds of John Carpenter's The Thing. Yeah. Because that is about the same amount of time that I watched the first John Wick movie on my first viewing. I have completed it, everyone. But Angela said she would watch that same length of any horror movie I chose. And I did. And I have no idea. what her reaction is. Don't tell me yet, but I cannot wait to hear your thoughts. And Angela, I want you to know that I tried really hard to pick a movie that was not just a horror movie, but also a classically great film. I didn't just try to give you some slasher scary thing. That's true. And I appreciate that. I truly knew nothing about this movie before I watched it. I did not Google it. I did not look it up. I really watched it not knowing anything. So it was just my honest reaction as I started watching it, and I will share that with you. All right. Well, we'll take a break and be right back.
而珍娜，作为我们常驻的恐怖片专家，你将对瑞恩对这个类型的尝试给出你的评价。我会的。我会的。我试着给出了我最好的评价。好吧。但这还不够，各位。我给安吉拉布置了一个任务，我对此兴奋极了。我让她去看了约翰·卡彭特的《怪形》的前24分30秒。对。因为那差不多就是我第一次看《疾速追杀》第一部时看的时间长度。各位，我已经看完了。但安吉拉说她会把我选的任何一部恐怖片都看同样的时长。我照做了。我完全不知道她的反应是什么。先别告诉我，但我已经迫不及待想听听你的感想了。安吉拉，我想让你知道，我真的很努力地挑选了一部电影，它不仅是一部恐怖片，同时也是一部经典伟大的电影。我可不是随随便便拿了一部血浆四溅的吓人玩意儿来敷衍你。确实如此。我很感激这一点。在看这部电影之前，我真的对它一无所知。我没有谷歌它，也没有去查资料。我真的是在什么都不知道的情况下看的。所以这纯粹是我在观看时的真实反应，我会跟你分享这些的。好了，那我们休息一下，马上回来。
This is an ad by BetterHelp. You know, it feels like nowadays there's advice for just about everything. It's like, do you write in your journal, do you do, I don't know, cleanses or the cold plunge or, you know, what helps you get through the day? What helps you get through stressful moments? Mm-hmm. For me, it's talking it out. Mm-hmm. Well, there can be a lot of information overload about mental health and wellness, and it can be a struggle to know what's true and what actions to take these days.
这是一条来自 BetterHelp 的广告。你知道，感觉现在不管什么事都有人给你出谋划策。就好像，你有没有写日记的习惯，你有没有做过，我不知道，排毒疗程、冷水浴，或者说，什么能帮你度过难关？什么能帮你应对压力时刻？嗯哼。对我来说，就是把事情说出来。嗯哼。好吧，关于心理健康和健康生活，可能会有大量的信息轰炸，如今要想知道什么是真的、该采取什么行动，可能是一件很纠结的事。
So you might think about using a trusted resource and talking to live therapists through better help. It has an app store rating of 4.9 out of 5 based on over 1.7 million client reviews. As the largest online therapy provider in the world, BetterHelp can provide access to mental health professionals with a diverse variety of expertise. Talk it out with BetterHelp. Our listeners get 10% off their first month at BetterHelp.com slash office ladies. That's BetterHelp, H-E-L-P.com slash office ladies. All right, we are back, and this webisode series has some really fun bonus content. on Peacock.
所以你可能会考虑通过 BetterHelp 寻找一个值得信赖的资源，与在线治疗师进行交流。它在应用商店里获得了4.9分的高分（满分5分），这是基于超过170万客户评价得出的。作为全球最大的在线心理疗法提供商，BetterHelp 可以为你提供拥有各种专业专长的心理健康专业人士。通过 BetterHelp 把心里话说出来吧。我们的听众在 BetterHelp.com/officeladies 首次订阅的前一个月可享九折优惠。网址是 BetterHelp，即 H-E-L-P.com/officeladies。好了，我们回来了，这个网络剧集系列在 Peacock 上有一些非常有趣的独家花絮内容。
Like, there is this cool black and white film flipbook of behind the scenes of this shoot. It was really fun to watch. And you know what? There's also some interviews with the cast. I thought we should kick this off with what Mindy and BJ had to say about this Webisode series. The episodes are following the tradition of the characters wanting to put on a show. Ryan is directing a horror film that he thinks will be sort of.
比如，这里有一本很酷的黑白电影翻页书，里面记录了这次拍摄的幕后花絮。看着非常有趣。你知道吗？里面还有一些对演员的采访。我觉得我们应该先听听明迪和 BJ 对这个网络剧集系列的看法。这些剧集延续了角色们想要“搞个演出”的传统。瑞恩在导演一部他认为类似于办公室版《灵动：鬼影实录》的恐怖片，由纪录片摄制组和办公室里的主要角色们共同记录下那些容易被忽视的细节，我觉得这是在网络剧集中展现的最佳方式。所以我真的很喜欢当大家组成那个名为“微妙性暗示”的女孩乐队时，就是凯莉和艾伦弄的那支乐队，我也很喜欢他们正在一起拍的这部恐怖片。办公室里的每个人都对这些副业完全置之不理，这其实挺搞笑的，而不知怎么的，我们在网络剧集里把它们捕捉了下来。我也挺喜欢这一点。所以能够探索瑞恩的激情所在或业余爱好，真的很有趣。而且我猜他是个狂热的恐怖片粉丝。嗯，我觉得更准确地说，他是对电影制作充满热情。在我看来，这有点符合他的一贯特质，就像他之前有一段时间迷上摄影那样。我觉得恐怖片这一部分只是他通往“电影导演”之路的一种方式。哦，是的，还有娱乐业。好吧，还有更多演员采访。我们会在节目进行中穿插播放。好吧，这里有一些关于这个网络剧集的数据。它于2010年10月28日发布。当时正值《办公室》第七季播出期间。我们在播出这集网络剧集的同一天播出了《万圣节化妆舞会》那一集。这算是我们对万圣节的一种致敬。这集网络剧集还获得了一项威比奖提名。所以第一集标题是《凯莉和艾伦翻篇了》。这一系列网络剧集由凯莉·海南、乔纳森·休斯和玛丽·沃尔编剧，由明迪·卡灵执导。
the paranormal activity set in an office picked up by the documentary crew and by the main characters in the office like the little things that fall through the cracks i think that's the best thing to show in webisodes so i really liked when the group did a subtle sexuality that girl band that kelly and aaron did and i really like this horror film that they're all working on it's funny like the side projects that just get completely ignored by everyone in the office and somehow for the web episodes we capture them i like that i'll do too so it's really fun that they get to explore what Ryan's passions or hobbies are. And I guess he's a big horror film fan. Well, I think it's more that he's a filmmaking fan. And this, to me, kind of goes with
（注：对应前台台词串音，原翻译已覆盖）
his character trait of how he got into photography for a while. I feel like the horror movie part is just his way into being a, like, film director. Oh, yes, and entertainment. Well, there's more cast interviews. We'll sprinkle those in as we go. Well, here are a few stats about this webisode. It was released on October 28th, 2010. This was during season seven of the office. We aired the episode costume contest the same day as this webisode. It was kind of our nod to Halloween. This webisode was also nominated for a Webby Award. So episode one is titled Kelly and Aaron Move On. This whole series of webisodes were written by Kelly Hannan, Jonathan Hughes, and Mary Wall, and they were directed by Mindy Kaling.
Here is your summary. Kelly and Aaron are going to pivot away from subtle sexuality. They're not going to make music anymore. Their new creative outlet is going to be acting in Ryan's horror film. Yeah. As a series starts, we are at front reception. Kelly and Aaron are listening to the tail end of their song. I'm just the girl next door.
以下是剧情梗概。凯莉和艾伦决定从“微妙性暗示”转型。她们不再唱歌了。她们的新创意发泄口将是在瑞恩的恐怖片里演戏。是的。剧集一开始，我们在前台接待处。凯莉和艾伦正在听她们那首歌的结尾部分。我只是隔壁的女孩。
Aaron thinks it's their best one yet. But they are disappointed by how many views the video is getting. It's not getting very many. Two. Two. That's it. That's it. Dare I say it's the two of them watching it. Kelly declares that music and dance are dead.
艾伦觉得这是她们迄今为止最好的一首。但她们对这支视频的播放量感到很失望。播放量少得可怜。两个。两个。就这。就这。我敢说，这俩播放量就是她俩自己贡献的。凯莉宣称音乐和舞蹈已经死了。
That's it. That must be the reason. Yes, that's why. Erin does add it's also the economy. Oh, okay. So there are multiple reasons. They say maybe it's time to move on. But don't worry, they're not giving up on fame.
就是这样。这肯定就是原因。是的，这就是原因。艾伦补充说，这也跟经济形势有关。哦，好吧。所以原因有很多。她们说也许是时候翻篇了。不过别担心，她们并没有放弃成名。
They're just giving up on music. So we cut to a little sitting area outside the break room. Kelly and Aaron are now with Kevin. They are sitting on the floor. They're having a floor chat. Yes, like a little brainstorming session. I've never seen this staging before. I found it super creative and interesting and fun. Fun. Yeah, I loved it. It kind of reminded me a little bit about when there was that group in the little supply closet having a meeting like Kelly and Toby. Yes, that was added back to the super fan episode. of what was that hot girl? Yes. Yeah.
她们只是放弃了音乐。所以镜头切换到茶水间外面的一处小休息区。凯莉和艾伦现在和凯文在一起。她们正坐在地板上。她们在进行一场“地板茶话会”。是的，就像是一个小型头脑风暴会议。我以前从没见过这种舞台调度。我觉得超级有创意、有趣而且好玩。好玩。对，我很喜欢。这让我想起了之前有一集里，那群人在小储藏室里开会，就像凯莉和托比那样。对，那是后来加到超级粉丝版里的一段。那是哪个辣妹的那集？对。对。
Yeah. It was a really, really creative way to shoot this. Kelly has like a little pad of paper, I guess for her brainstorming session. I need you to hear how Kelly kicks things off. Okay. I want to express myself, but I have nothing to say in no medium with which to do it. That's it. She has something she wants to say. She doesn't know what it is.
对。拍摄手法真的非常有创意。凯莉带了一个小记事本，我想那是用来做头脑风暴的。我需要让你听听凯莉是怎么开场的。好吧。我想表达自己，但我无话可说，也没有任何媒介可以用来表达。就是这样。她有话想说。但她不知道那是什么。
She has no way to do it. Go. Go, give it to me. Kevin, you're up. Well, Kevin explains that there's more than one way to express yourself, and he reveals that he writes poetry. What? All along, Kevin is a poet? He reads one of his haikus. Here's what it is. Beauty approaches. I am brought under its spell. I long to be with. That's it. Because he ran out of syllables. We'll never know. Ryan is in the adjacent room, and he is yelling at someone over the phone. He's very upset. Yes. He's talking about, like, ancient zombies, traipsing through Scranton out for blood.
她没有任何办法去表达。开始。开始吧，说给我听听。凯文，轮到你了。好吧，凯文解释说表达自己的方式不止一种，并透露他会写诗。什么？凯文一直以来竟然是个诗人？他朗读了自己写的一首俳句。内容是这样的：美景临近。我被它摄取了心魂。我渴望与……就这。因为他用光了音节。我们永远也不会知道了。瑞恩在隔壁房间，正在对着电话对某人大喊大叫。他非常生气。是的。他说的好像是什么古老的僵尸踩着斯克兰顿布满路坑的街道寻找鲜血。
Ryan is on the phone with someone trying to get them to participate. Mm-hmm. It sounds like he needs... Would you say? Yes. It sounds like he needs a lot of background actors to play zombies. Yes. And we find out that he is called the Evergreen Old Folks Home. Yes. I need to play this talking head where Ryan describes the film he's trying to make, but more than anything, I need you to hear when it cuts back to his side of the phone call with the
瑞恩正在和某人通电话，试图让他们参与进来。嗯哼。听起来他需要……你觉得呢？对。听起来他需要大量的群演来扮演僵尸。对。然后我们发现他给常青树老人之家打了电话。是的。我必须播放这段访谈，瑞恩在其中描述了他想拍的电影，但最重要的是，当镜头切回他和养老院经理的电话那头时，我需要你听听他说的话，因为他说的那些话简直把我逗笑了。想象一下这个画面：五十个古老的僵尸踩着斯克兰顿布满路坑的街道，出来寻找鲜血。听起来很吓人，对吧？可惜你永远也看不到这一幕了，因为常青树老人之家的那个白痴经理觉得这听起来有剥削嫌疑，所以我们现在就卡在这儿了。好吧，你歇斯底里的程度让我觉得你可能并不是负责人。这里有主管吗？我希望如此，你歇斯底里的程度让我觉得你根本不是负责人。看我写了什么：这一集里我最喜欢的台词就是瑞恩说“好吧，你歇斯底里的程度让我觉得你不是负责人”。我简直想把这句话写在便签上，下次我在客服电话里遇到不肯帮我忙的人时，就可以派上用场了。你知道它让我想起了什么吗。某种类似的话。比如，你这种毫无帮助的程度让我觉得你不是负责人。这其实让我想起了凯西，因为你们怎么称呼凯西的，你和你的伴侣关于有线电视的那个电话。我有同感。我有同感。我想着凯西应该说：“好吧，你歇斯底里的程度让我觉得你不是负责人。”
manager of the retirement home, because what he says just cracked me up. Picture this. Fifty ancient zombies traipsing through the pothole-ridden streets of Scranton, out for blood. Sounds scary, right? too bad you'll never see it because the idiot manager at the evergreen old folks home thinks it sounds exploitative so that's where we're at right now okay your level of hysteria makes me think maybe you're not in charge is there a supervisor I hope that's what your level of hysteria makes me believe you're not in charge look what I wrote my favorite line in this episode is when Ryan says okay your level of
（注：接上条台词串音）
hysteria makes me think you're not in charge I literally want to, like, put that on a post-it note for the next time I might need it when I'm trying to talk to somebody who is not helping me on a customer service call. You know what it made me. Some version of that. Like, your level of helpfulness is making me think you're not in charge. It actually made me think of Cassie because how you guys call Cassie, you and your partner call about your cable. I thought the same thing. I thought the same thing. I was like, Cassie needs to say, okay, your level of hysteria makes me think you're not in charge.
I'll try it in the next six months when we have to make that call. So Ryan explains his situation to Kelly, like what's going on, and Kelly volunteers to be in the movie. Yeah. Ryan is going to reject this idea. But then Kelly's like, look, I scream all the time. I'm really good at screaming. I can scream for free. And he's like, okay, fine, fine. Yeah, he says, if the director of paranormal activity can make it work. So can he. Yeah. I'll have you know I've not ever seen paranormal activity. Well, shocker, neither have I. Sam? The first one is very, very good. Yes. You guys have seen it? Yes, the rest of the six or seven you can skip. Six or seven. I'm not kidding, but the first one is really good. I can't watch, I have some limits. Oh, I didn't know this. Yeah, I was going to explain this a little later when I was sort of talking about my passion for horrible.
我会在接下来的六个月里，在我们不得不打那个电话时试试看。所以瑞恩向凯莉解释了他的处境，也就是发生了什么，凯莉自告奋勇想参演这部电影。是的。瑞恩本来想拒绝这个想法。但凯莉接着说：听着，我随时都在尖叫。我非常擅长尖叫。我可以免费尖叫。然后他说：好吧，好吧，好吧。对，他说，如果《灵动：鬼影实录》的导演能成功的话。他也可以。对。我得声明一下，我从来没看过《灵动：鬼影实录》。好吧，真让人震惊，我也没看过。山姆？第一部真的非常非常好看。是的。你们看过吗？看过，剩下的六七部你们可以跳过。六七部。我没开玩笑，但第一部真的很好。我可看不了，我有些底线。哦，我以前不知道这个。对，我待会儿会稍微解释一下，当我谈到我对烂片的狂热时，但我不太喜欢超自然恐怖片或者鬼屋故事。而《灵动：鬼影实录》这两者有点兼而有之。是因为你觉得它可能会成真吗？我可不想在自己的家里感到毛骨悚然。比如，如果听到任何吱吱声或怪声，我本来就已经有睡眠问题了。所以我不需要这方面的额外刺激。太有趣了，因为那是我唯一喜欢看的恐怖片类型。真的吗？对，我只喜欢鬼故事。我不喜欢有人试图杀我、捅我。你看，我又没法跟鬼搏斗。所以，我不知道该怎么赢得那种局面。哦。对，我想这是因为我不相信这世上有鬼。所以它……对，我的意思是，我们讨论过我衣柜里有个女鬼之类的事情。
movies, but I don't love supernatural horror or haunted house stories. And paranormal activity is kind of both. Is it because you could believe it? I don't want to feel creeped out in my own home. Like, I already have a problem sleeping if I hear any creaks or noises. So I don't need, like, extra food for that. That's so interesting because that's the only type of horror movie I like to watch. Really? Yeah, I only like ghost stories. I don't like someone trying to kill and stab me. See, I can't fight back against a ghost. So, like, I don't know how to win that scenario. Oh. Yeah, I think it's because I don't believe in it. So it's... Yeah, I mean, we've talked about how I have the lady in my closet and all that stuff.
听着。所以我才不需要去想象她生我的气什么的。对。我是说，我可不会去招惹灵异世界。你知道我的意思吗？这就是我的感受。就像，我绝对不会去招惹它们。我想我跟你们分享过，我曾经去为电影《招魂》中的一个角色试镜。他们把剧本发给了我。那是我们在拍《办公室》的时候。最后我因为档期冲突没去成。但他们把剧本发给我了。我就想，哦，我读读看。然后我在《办公室》片场的房车里读它，正是在我休息的时候。我简直吓坏了。把乌鸦都吓跑了。把乌鸦都吓跑了。拉波拉，仅仅是读剧本。哇。把我吓得魂飞魄散。不过我在想，参演这部电影会不会算是一种治疗呢，因为你会看到这一切其实有多么假？不，不，不，但这可是根据真实故事改编的。哦，对，没错。那部是的。它是根据真实故事改编的。而且我确实看过那部电影，真的很好看。对。好吧，不管怎样，好吧，你对这个题材确实是有底线的。我很高兴知道这一点。
Listen. So I just don't need to imagine her getting angry at me or anything. Yeah. I mean, I am like, I am not messing with the spirit world. You know what I'm saying? That's how I feel. Like, I am not messing with it. I think I've shared this with you guys that I was going to audition for a role in the movie The Conjuring. And they sent me the script. And this is when we were on the office. And I ultimately had a conflict. But they sent me the script. And I was like, oh, I'll read it. And I was reading it in my trailer on the set of the office, like on my break. And I was so terrified. It scared the crows. It scared the crows. Rapola, just reading it. Wow. Scared the crap out of me. I wonder if being in the movie would have been some sort of like therapy for that, though, because you would see how fake it was. No, no, no, but it's based on a true story. Oh, yeah, that's right. That one is. It's based on a true story. And I did see that movie and it's really good. Yeah. Okay. Anyway, okay, so you do have limits to this genre. I'm glad to know that.
（注：接上条台词串音）
I do. Because I don't want to watch anything where some ghost is coming for me ever, ever. Well, I did not pick that for you. I know. Well, this episode of the web series ends with Kelly and Aaron. They're so excited that they're going to be in this movie, you know, that they're back. And they start singing this little song, and it goes like this. We found our outlet. We found our outlet.
我有。因为我可不想看任何有鬼魂来找我的电影，绝对、绝对不要。好吧，我可没为你选那种片子。我知道。好吧，网络剧集的这一集以凯莉和艾伦的场景结束。她们太兴奋了，因为她们能演这部电影，你知道的，她们又回来了。然后她们开始唱起这首小曲，歌词是这样的：我们找到了宣泄口。我们找到了宣泄口。
No more singing and dancing for us. We found our outlet. We found an outlet. We found an outlet. Go to two minutes and 34 seconds because Kate Flannery is just being Kate. She's not Meredith at all in this moment. Look at her. She's just Kate. She's just eating chips. Yeah. Kind of bobbing her head to their song. Yeah. All right. Next up, episode two titled Lights Camera Action. It opens with Angela making a copy on the copy machine when Aaron
我们再也不用唱歌跳舞了。我们找到了宣泄口。我们找到了宣泄口。我们找到了宣泄口。快进到两分三十四秒，因为凯特·弗兰纳里简直就是在做她自己。此刻的她一点也不像梅雷迪思。看看她。她就是凯特。她只是在吃薯片。对。一边听着她们的歌一边晃着脑袋。对。接下来，第二集，标题是《灯光、摄像机、开拍》。开场是安吉拉在复印机前复印文件，这时艾伦
wielding a butcher knife jumps out and scares her. Angela is very upset, but Ryan is thrilled. He is thrilled. He says, Aaron, you were amazing. And then he turns to Angela so earnestly and goes, You are so good. And Angela's like, I am just scared. And Angela comes to find out that the knife that Aaron is wielding at her is not even a fake knife. They were too expensive, Ryan says. We have plenty of real knives. They probably should have got a faky knife that looked more like a real knife because that knife is so clearly fake. I thought it looked like a faking knife, too. That's so funny. Well, you know, when we rehearsed the scene, they said, okay, Angela, they didn't know what I screamed like. You know, they were like, you're going to get a jump scare. Just scream like you're terrified. And Brian, as Kevin is standing kind of close to me, and I screamed like I screamed.
挥舞着一把屠夫刀突然跳出来吓了她一跳。安吉拉非常生气，但瑞恩却兴奋极了。他兴奋极了。他说：艾伦，你演得太棒了。然后他极其诚恳地转过身对安吉拉说：你演得真好。安吉拉则是一脸：我特么只是被吓到了。接着安吉拉发现，艾伦在她面前挥舞的那把刀甚至都不是道具假刀。瑞恩说，道具太贵了。我们有的是真刀。他们本来应该弄一把看起来更像真刀的假刀，因为那把刀实在是太假了。我也觉得那看起来像把假刀。太搞笑了。好吧，你知道的，当我们排练这场戏的时候，他们说：好吧，安吉拉，他们不知道我的尖叫声是什么样的。你知道的，他们说：你会被吓一跳的。就装出被吓坏了的样子尖叫一声。而布莱恩扮演的凯文就站在离我挺近的地方，我发出了那种尖叫声。
And Brian looked at me like, what the hell? It kind of made him jump. Now, here's my question. We have discussed that when you jump scare Angela Kinsey, she might kick or punch you. Yes. Because you really do not like it. My first instinct is to hit. Yes. So how was this for you shooting this? I feel like this is your tickling scene. Remember how I really hate being tickled, but I had to let Roy tickle Pam and Pam had to like it? It went against all my instincts. This was okay for me because Angela is angry. Okay. She's furious. She kind of slams the papers down on the copier. And so that was, I could play that. You could use it. I could. I was furious that they were jump scaring me.
然后布莱恩看着我，那表情仿佛在说：搞什么鬼？这甚至把他给吓了一跳。现在，我的问题来了。我们讨论过，当你想吓安吉拉·金西时，她可能会踢你或揍你。是的。因为你真的很讨厌这样。我的第一反应就是打人。是的。所以你拍这场戏的时候感觉怎么样？我觉得这就像是你的“胳肢戏”。还记得我有多讨厌被胳肢吗，但我当时不得不让罗伊去胳肢帕姆，而帕姆还必须表现得很享受？这完全违背了我的本能。这场戏对我来说还可以，因为安吉拉当时很生气。好吧。她气炸了。她把文件“啪”地一声摔在复印机上。所以那个，我可以演出来。你能用得上。我可以。我对他们吓唬我的行为感到怒不可遏。
Okay. Well, in this moment, we also finally get to see Aaron's costume. Right? And Mindy and Ellie share in these behind-the-scenes interviews about it. I am the monster. I'm a combination of Jeffrey Dahmer on, let's see, this side and Lizzie Borden on this side. She looks hideous. When I first saw her, like they would bring her in, like, Laverne brought her in, costumes, right? And we're like, what do you think? And I was, like, recoiled because it was so good. It was like so gruesome and terrible. Oh, I have no doubt that hair, makeup, and costumes had so much fun with this. Oh, yeah. I do love that Mindy said she looked hideous. I reached out to Ellie about this. I sent her a screen grab of her in this costume. And I said, Ellie, please tell me anything that you
好吧，在这个时刻，我们终于看到了艾伦的造型。对吧？明迪和艾莉在这些幕后采访中分享了相关感受。我是个怪物。我是一半杰夫·达默（注：美国连环杀手），再加上，让我们看看，这边是莉齐·波顿（注：美国疑似谋杀犯）。她看起来太吓人了。我第一次见到她的时候，他们把她带过来，就像拉韦恩带她来试造型一样，对吧？然后我们说：你觉得怎么样？我当时直接退缩了，因为实在是太棒了。看起来血淋淋的，太可怕了。哦，毫无疑问，发型、化妆和服装部门在这次造型上玩得太开心了。哦，对。我真的很喜欢明迪说她看起来很吓人。我为此联系了艾莉。我给她发了一张她在剧中这个造型的截图。我说：艾莉，请告诉我任何你
remember about the hair and makeup process for this look. And I sent her a picture of herself as this character. And she wrote, and then she said, oh my goodness, this webisode, I loved it. That was absolutely the longest I was in hair and makeup at the office. Wow. It was two to three hours. Wow. Yeah. She said, and get this, I still have the poster. She said, but I don't know where to display it. Oh, they made a poster? They made a poster of her looking like that. Okay, that's pretty cool. I know.
记得的关于这个造型的发型和化妆过程的细节。我还发了一张她扮演这个角色的照片。她回复了，然后她说：哦天哪，这集网络剧集，我太爱了。绝对是我在《办公室》里待在化妆间时间最长的一次。哇。花了整整两到三个小时。哇。对，她说，你绝对想不到，我还留着那张海报。她说，但我不知道该把它挂在哪里。哦，他们还做了海报？他们把她这副尊容做成了一张海报。好吧，这挺酷的。我知道。
But I also get why maybe she isn't hanging it in the hallway. She should just hang it up as a Halloween decoration every year. Oh, that's a great idea. Yeah. Okay, well, Jenna, as our resident horror movie expert, what did you think of Ellie's costume as this monster character? I thought it was fantastic. I thought they did a great job with it. It was very, very creative.
但我大概也能理解为什么她没有把它挂在走廊里。她每年万圣节把它挂起来当装饰不就行了。哦，这主意真不错。对。好吧，那么珍娜，作为我们常驻的恐怖片专家，你觉得艾莉扮演这个怪物的造型怎么样？我觉得太棒了。我觉得他们在这个造型上做得非常出色。非常有、非常有创意。
But the costuming I really want to talk about is Ryan as the horror movie director. Oh, I had a whole thing that says right here, we have got to break down Ryan's outfit. Yeah, I would describe it as full douchebag. That's great. And in my limited time in the sort of horror movie circles through my fandom and getting to meet the horror movie director. They really do dress like that. Do they really? I mean, he's got on the Elvis sunglasses from like the Vegas years.
但我真正想聊的服装是瑞恩作为恐怖片导演的行头。哦，我这儿正好有一条笔记写着：我们必须好好剖析一下瑞恩的穿搭。对，我会把它形容为“十足的人渣风”。太绝了。以我通过粉丝身份和结识恐怖片导演而积累的有限的恐怖片圈子经验来看，他们确实是那样穿的。真的吗？我是说，他戴着猫王拉斯韦加斯时期的那种太阳镜。
He's got on a zip-up hoodie. And like a beanie. Yes, but his zip-up hoodie isn't just a normal zip-up hoodie. It looks like the x-ray of someone's chest. I mean, listen. The rib cage. Maybe they don't dress like this anymore. But like back in the day, it was a really weird way of dressing.
他穿着一件拉链连帽衫。还戴了一顶无檐帽。对，但他的拉链连帽衫可不是普通的拉链连帽衫。它看起来就像是某个人的胸腔X光片。我是说，听着。肋骨图案。也许他们现在不这么穿了。但在过去，那真是一种非常奇特的穿衣风格。
and it made me laugh out loud when I saw him. I was like, I have literally met that guy. I think I actually know who they are satirizing with that outfit. Like, I think I know. I won't say. Oh, come on. But I think I know who it is. And it made me laugh out loud.
当我看到他时，我忍不住笑出了声。我就想：我真的遇到过那种人。我想我大概知道他们这套服装是在讽刺谁。真的，我觉得我知道。我就不说是谁了。哦，得了吧。但我觉得我知道是谁。这让我大笑出声。
You have to tell me later. Yes. I love the guy. But yes, there's like a whole like presentational outfit. Oh my gosh. I have no idea who this is. Yeah. Well, now Gabe is talking to Ryan, and he's explaining to Ryan, look, you can't scare people in the office.
你待会儿一定要告诉我。对。我很喜欢那个家伙。不过确实，有那么一套标志性的“导演造型”。天哪。我完全不知道这是谁。好吧，现在加比正在跟瑞恩说话，他在向瑞恩解释：听着，你不能在办公室里吓唬人。
Yeah, Ryan's like, I'm sorry. I don't remember seeing anything in the handbook about not being able to shoot horror films in the office. And Gabe is like, well, it does say you cannot bring weapons to work. Right then, Aaron appears with an axe, and Kelly yells for Gabe to run. Gabe is completely panicked. He's in a corner. He's like, there's nowhere. Run, where?
对，瑞恩则说：我很抱歉。我不记得员工手册上有哪条规定说不能在办公室里拍恐怖片的。而加比则说：嗯，上面确实写着你不能把武器带到办公室来。就在这时，艾伦拿着一把斧头出现了，凯莉大喊让加比快跑。加比彻底慌了。他被逼到了角落。他说：无处可逃。快跑，往哪跑？
There's nowhere to run. And then Ryan's like, got it, got the shot. Yes. Turns out Kevin was filming from over at Kelly's desk. Then Gabe is now angry at them. And he says, quote, it is petrifying and frankly unprofessional, this behavior. To which Ryan replies, it's unprofessional for you. But for me, making films is my profession.
根本无处可逃。然后瑞恩说：有了，画面拍到了。是的。原来凯文正站在凯莉的办公桌那边拍摄呢。接着加比对他们火冒三丈。他说，原封不动地引用他的话：“这种行为简直令人毛骨悚然，坦白讲极其不专业。”对此瑞恩回应道：“对你来说是不专业。但对我来说，拍电影就是我的职业。”
Oh, Ryan. Oh, Ryan, Ryan, Ryan. Gabe threatens to. stop all production. And Ryan pivots quickly in the moment. And he's like, wait, your voice just then. It sounded so commanding. Yeah.
哦，瑞恩。哦，瑞恩，瑞恩，瑞恩。加比威胁要停掉所有制作。而瑞恩当即机敏地转变了态度。他说：等等，你刚才的声音。听起来太有威严了。是的。
And he asked him if he will be the voiceover talent for the movie, the narrator. Gabe is instantly flattered and agrees to do it. I want everyone to go to one minute, 36 seconds. Why? Everyone is breaking. They are. But DJ. What?
然后他问加比愿不愿意为这部电影担任画外音配音，也就是担任旁白。加比瞬间飘飘然了，并欣然同意。我想要大家快进到一分三十六秒。为什么？所有人都在笑场。确实如此。但是 BJ。什么？
Ellie is breaking, but she kind of just makes it part of her character. Mindy is trying really hard not to break. Brian is breaking so badly that he ducks behind BJ. He turns his body and tilts his head down. What are they laughing at? And then when it cuts back to Zach Woods, he looks like he's trying not to laugh. So I don't know what happened in that moment.
艾莉在笑场，但她顺势把这变成了她角色的一部分。明迪拼命忍住不笑场。布莱恩笑得太厉害了，以至于直接躲到了 BJ 身后。他转过身，把头低了下去。他们到底在笑什么？然后当镜头切回扎克·伍兹时，他看起来也在极力忍住不笑。所以我不知道那一刻发生了什么。
I have a feeling, Zach Woods improvised a few moments here. I bet he did. I mean, if I had to think about it, I feel like maybe he started doing some sort of like voiceover bit thing. Or when he says my voice is so nasal, it sounds like dot, dot, dot, I bet he gave them a bunch of different versions of what his nasally voice sounds like. You're probably right. But they are all losing it.
我有种直觉，扎克·伍兹在这里即兴发挥了一点东西。我敢说他绝对这么干了。如果让我猜的话，我觉得他可能开始搞某种画外音的模仿秀了。或者当他说“我的声音太有鼻音了，听起来就像……点点点”的时候，我敢打赌他给他们提供了一堆不同版本的鼻音效果。你可能猜对了。但他们全都破防了。
That's very funny. Well, Ryan realizes that he's going to be the first filmmaker to wear all four hats. Wow. Writer, director, actor, and producer. Wow. Gabe mentions that Clint Eastwood has already done that multiple times. But then Ryan says, but does he play his own? score. And he has a saxophone that he starts playing. Where has the saxophone been this whole
太搞笑了。好吧，瑞恩意识到自己将成为第一个包揽全部四个职位的电影制作人。哇。编剧、导演、演员和制片人。哇。加比提到克林特·伊斯特伍德已经多次做到这一点了。但瑞恩随即说道：那他会自己配乐吗？接着他拿出一把萨克斯开始吹奏起音乐。这把萨克斯在这整场戏之前到底藏在哪儿？
scene? It's just like ready to go? I guess so. And who knew that Ryan plays the saxophone? Who knew? This is the big reveal at the end of the episode. Kevin's a poet. Ryan plays the saxophone. We're learning so much. So much. Up next is episode three. It's titled The Final Product. And before we get into this breakdown, I have to share this little nugget from the behind the scenes interview. It's Zach Woods talking about trick-or-treating as a kid when he was growing up. It's hilarious. When I was a kid, I was really into Halloween. I got my friends together and we choreographed a full dance to the Bee Gees.
就这么随时准备着拿出来吹吗？我想是的。而且谁能想到瑞恩竟然会吹萨克斯？谁能想到？这是本集最后的重磅爆料。凯文是个诗人。瑞恩会吹萨克斯。我们学到了太多东西。太多了。接下来是第三集。标题是《最终成品》。在我们进入剧情剖析之前，我必须分享来自幕后采访的一个小花絮。这是扎克·伍兹在谈论他小时候长大过程中去讨糖果（Trick-or-treat）的经历。太搞笑了。当我还是个孩子的时候，我非常迷恋万圣节。我把我的朋友们聚在一起，为比吉乐队的歌编排了一整套舞蹈。
You know, the staying alive? I would lip-sync. We would bring a boom box and go from door to door, and then we would press play. And I would lip-sync staying alive. And they would do this whole choreograph dance behind me. I remember going to one man's door and doing this whole choreograph dance and day he was like, do you want candy? I can't wait all night. He got real irate and I remember immediately being like, oh, this was a terrible idea. I want to see footage of that. I need to see
你知道，就是那首《Staying Alive》吗？我来对口型。我们带了一个收音机挨家挨户地敲门，然后按下播放键。我就会对口型假唱《Staying Alive》。而他们会在我身后跳整套编排好的舞蹈。我记得有一次我去敲一个人的门，跳了那整套编排好的舞蹈，结果那个人说：你们要不要糖？我可没工夫在这儿等一晚上。他当时真的火冒三丈，我记得我立刻就意识到：天哪，这主意太糟了。我好想看那段录像。我真想看
Zach Woods as a kid hitting a doorbell saying trick or treat and then singing the beechees. Like, I need that in my life. I feel like we need to remind him of this story that he told because if you've done that, that's ingrained in you. Oh, yeah. I feel. feel like he could, he could, like, bust that out any time. Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. All right. Well, listen, episode three, the final product is exactly as advertised. It is the movie. Mm-hmm. There is this sort of opening title credit, and it's got a warning. It says, quote, the following preview has been approved by the Motion Picture Association of Evil and is suitable for sadistic audiences only. Watch at your own risk.
小时候的扎克·伍兹去按门铃说“不给糖就捣蛋”，然后唱着比吉乐队的歌。天哪，我的生活中太需要这个了。我觉得我们得提醒他一下他讲过的这个故事，因为如果你曾经做过这种事，那绝对是刻进DNA里的。哦，对。我觉得。我觉得他随时都能把这套绝活拿出来表演一番。哦，对。哦，对。好吧，听着，第三集《最终成品》正如宣传的那样。这就是那部电影。嗯哼。这里有一个类似于片头演职员表的环节，上面还有一个警告。上面写着，引述如下：“以下预告片已获恶魔电影协会批准，仅适合虐心向观众观看。观看风险自负。”
Yes, we open on a voiceover, and it's Gabe. And he is narrating that she thought it was just another typical day at work. And who he's talking about is Kelly, who is conducting an interview with Meredith, who is playing, what would you say, like a fortune teller type of woman? She's got a shawl over her head, kind of wrapped around her neck. She's got a patch over one eye. She wants to buy some paper, but she has no money. And when Kelly won't sell her paper, Meredith puts a curse on her. Yeah.
没错，我们从一段旁白开始，说话的是加比。他在旁白中说，她以为这只是工作中又极其平常的一天。他口中的“她”指的是凯莉，她正在对梅雷迪思进行面试，梅雷迪思扮演的是什么呢，你觉得就像是个算命先生之类的女性。她的头上搭着一条披肩，绕在脖子上。她一只眼睛戴着眼罩。她想买点纸，但她身无分文。当凯莉拒绝把纸卖给她时，梅雷迪思对她下了诅咒。是的。
She summons serial killers from the past to unite and haunt the third floor for all eternity. And Kelly's like, whatever, this is the second floor. So I'm all good. I'm not on the third floor. Yeah, it's fine. She doesn't care that she has caused a. curse for everyone on the third floor. You got it wrong, lady. Yeah. Now we see Kevin, and he's in his mall cop outfit. Remember his Halloween mall cop? Oh, yes. Yes. He's got a toupee, a mustache. He's like the
她召唤了过去的连环杀手们聚在一起，要在三楼阴魂不散直到永远。凯莉则是一副：随便啦，这里是二楼。所以我好得很。我又不在三楼。是的，没关系。她才不在乎自己给三楼的所有人都招来了诅咒。你找错人了，大姐。是的。现在我们看到了凯文，他穿着商场保安的制服。还记得他那个万圣节商场保安造型吗？哦，对。是的。他戴着假发块、留着胡子。他扮演的就是那个保安角色。是的。而且光线很暗。他正拿着手电筒。他在走廊里，大概在电梯间和万斯冷冻公司外面。然后他看到了之前拿着斧头的艾伦。是的。这其实是个很酷的镜头。你随后能看到他的影子，还能看到一把斧头的影子在疯狂劈砍他的影子，鲜血四溅。镜头切到了克里德。他有一个单人访谈镜头。伙计们，他是个记者。他戴着一顶帽子，还戴着一个写着“记者”字样的小牌子。他是。我需要让你听听这段访谈，因为他会告诉你发生了什么，简直棒极了。我从未见过这样的场景。拥有莉齐·波顿的右臂，杰夫的左臂……
security guard character. Yes. And it's dark. He's using his flashlight. He's in the hallway, kind of out by the elevator bay and Vance Refrigeration. And he sees Aaron wielding the axe from earlier. Yes. It's actually a cool shot. You sort of then see. a shadow of him and you see a shadow of an axe hacking at the shadow of him and like blood splurting everywhere. It cuts to Creed. He has a talking head. You guys, he's a member of the press. He has a hat and he has a little sign that says press. He is. And I need you to hear this talking head because he's going to tell you what's happened and it's great. I've never seen anything like it. Has the right arm of Lizzie Borden, the left arm of Jeffrey.
保安角色。对。而且天很黑。他在用手电筒。他在走廊里，靠近电梯间和万斯冷气公司。他看到亚伦拿着之前的那把斧头。对。这其实是一个很酷的镜头。然后你会看到他的影子，看到一把斧头的影子在砍他的影子，血到处飞溅。镜头切到克里德。他有一个访谈镜头。伙计们，他是记者团的成员。他戴着一顶帽子，拿有一个写着“记者”的小牌子。他是。我需要你们听这段访谈，因为他会告诉你们发生了什么，这太棒了。我从来没见过这样的事。拥有莉齐·博登的右臂，杰弗里的左臂。
Domer, the heart of Jack the Ripper, and the legs of all the serial killers who ever got away. So there you have it. That's our monster. I also love the callback to saxophone playing. Oh, I didn't even, I just heard that in that clip. This is right. He is playing the score. You're right. So during this creed talking head, as he's describing the monster, we see Aaron as. the monster in B-roll, she's got an axe in her Lizzie Borden hand, she has a fork in her Jeffrey Dahmer hand, and then you see her sort of like wobbly legs getting ready to run. Erin now goes after Angela, then Gabe.
多莫，开膛手杰克的心脏，还有所有逍遥法外的连环杀手的双腿。好了，这就是我们的怪物。我也很喜欢对萨克斯演奏的致敬。哦，我甚至没注意到，我只是在那个片段里听到了。没错。他在演奏配乐。你说得对。所以在这个克里德的访谈镜头里，当他在描述怪物时，我们在花絮镜头里看到艾伦扮演了那个怪物，她的丽兹·博登之手拿着一把斧头，她的杰弗里·多莫之手拿着一把叉子，然后你看到她像摇摇晃晃的腿一样准备开跑。艾伦现在去追安吉拉，然后是盖布。
Yep. Kelly asks the janitor, who's being played by Ryan, why are these crimes happening on the second floor? Remember? Because it's the third floor that's curse. Well, he tells her, they added a basement during. renovations. So this is the third floor. Kelly's like, Kelly begs the old woman to reverse the curse. But it's too late. The murdering corpse of
没错。凯利问由瑞安饰演的看门人，为什么这些罪行会发生在二楼？还记得吗？因为三楼才是受诅咒的。好吧，他告诉她，他们在装修时加了个地下室。所以这里是三楼。凯利就像是，凯利恳求老妇人解除诅咒。但为时已晚。那个谋杀成性的尸体
Aaron appears at Kelly's cubicle and then sort of like low speed chases her through the office as Kelly begs for her life. She tries to throw a candy dish. That does make Aaron trip for a minute. This is true. She does trip. But she bouncing. bounces back up. And when Kelly opens the elevator door, she's like hitting the button, hitting the button. Yep. And it opens and there is Erin. Inside the elevator. She's transported. Yeah. And she kills Kelly. The title card flashes on the screen. The third floor. Coming to theaters, TBD. TBD. And there you have it. There you have it. How fun to shoot this. It was really fun. I love doing my scene. And I know, Ellie, had a blast as well. These episodes were always so much fun. Yeah. Because you got to just do so many
艾伦出现在凯利的工位旁，然后以低速在办公室里追赶她，而凯利则苦苦求饶。她试图扔出一个糖果盘。这确实让艾伦绊倒了一会儿。千真万确。她确实绊倒了。但她马上又弹了起来。当凯利打开电梯门时，她一直在狂按按钮，狂按按钮。没错。门开了，艾伦就在里面。在电梯里面。她被传送到那儿了。是的。然后她杀了凯利。片名字幕在屏幕上闪现。三楼。即将上映，待定。待定。事情就是这样。事情就是这样。拍摄这个过程太好玩了。真的非常有趣。我很喜欢拍我自己的那场戏。而且我知道，埃莉也玩得很开心。这些剧集总是那么有趣。是的。因为你可以做很多
wacky things. But lady, let's go to break because when we come back, Jenna, will you give us your overall assessment of Ryan's movie? I will. And Angela, you will share with us about watching the first 24 minutes and 30 seconds of John Carpenter's The Thing. I will. Get to Toronto's main venues like Budweiser Stage and the new Roger Stadium with Go Transit. Thanks to Go Transit's special online e-ticket fairs, a $10 one-day weekend pass offers unlimited travel on any weekend day or holiday anywhere along the Go Network. And the weekday group passes offer the same weekday travel flexibility across the network, starting at $30 for two people and up to $60 for a group of five. Buy your online go pass ahead of the show at go-transit.com slash tickets. We are back.
古怪的事情。不过各位，我们先去休息一下，因为回来后，珍娜，你能给我们评价一下瑞安的电影吗？我会的。还有安吉拉，你会跟我们分享你观看约翰·卡朋特的《怪形》前24分30秒的感受吗。我会的。搭乘Go Transit前往多伦多主要场馆，如百威舞台和全新的罗杰斯体育场。借助Go Transit特别的在线电子车票优惠，10美元的一日周末通票可在任何周末或节假日于Go网络沿线任意地点无限次换乘。平日团体票则提供同样贯穿整个网络的平日出行灵活性，两人30美元起，五人团体最高60美元。在演出前登录go-transit.com/tickets购买您的在线Go通票。我们回来了。
All right, Jenna. Let us know how does Ryan's movie fare on your horror movie scale. Okay. I wanted to do a good job with my critique. Okay. So according to the Internet AI, there are certain elements that all good horror movies have. Oh. And I agreed.
好的，珍娜。让我们听听瑞安的电影在你的恐怖片评分标准里表现如何。好的。我想把我的影评做好。好的。根据互联网人工智能的说法，所有优秀的恐怖片都有某些共同元素。哦。我表示赞同。
Oh. So a great horror movie is a blend of atmosphere. I would add that a good horror movie also has a few jump scares and a great villain. Whatever that villain might be, maybe it's a ghost, maybe it's an actual monster, maybe it's your own dark thoughts. Okay. Okay. I think Ryan's film has it all. Wow.
哦。所以一部伟大的恐怖片是氛围的融合。我要补充的是，一部优秀的恐怖片还会有一些突发惊吓和一个出色的反派。无论这个反派是什么，也许是个鬼魂，也许是个真正的怪物，也许是你自己黑暗的想法。好吧。好吧。我觉得瑞安的电影应有尽有。哇。
Yeah. Are you surprised? I thought it was great. I thought it was a really good. about if I am a local filmmaker and I'm making a movie in my office with my friends, I thought it was excellent. Wow. I thought it had a great plot. The plot was very clear. I thought it had good suspense. I thought there was great atmosphere with Kevin as a security guard, kind of wandering dark in the hallway. Like, I thought it was a great use of the space. Like, again, if I'm imagining
对。你很吃惊吗？我觉得它太棒了。我觉得这真的很棒。如果我是一个当地的电影制作人，我和朋友们在办公室里拍了一部电影，我觉得它太棒了。哇。我觉得它有一个很棒的情节。情节非常清晰。我觉得它有很好的悬念。我觉得凯文作为一个保安在走廊黑暗中游荡，营造了很棒的氛围。就像，我觉得它对空间的利用太棒了。就像，再次强调，如果我假设
that Ryan is a real person and Dunder Mifflin is a real place. I thought he used the space creatively. I thought it was shot well. I mean, probably because Matt Sone was shooting it, but it's shot very well. But I would argue that there is one thing that it is missing. What? I think a good horror movie has creative kills. Oh. And in this one, we kind of get the same kill over and over. It's just sort of the same bloody handprint going down a wall. Well, that might have been all of the special effects they could afford. And also, because the people they were killing, they weren't part of the movie. So they couldn't really, all they were getting was just like someone screaming and then a
瑞安是一个真人，邓德米夫林是一个真实的地方。我觉得他对空间的利用很有创意。我觉得它拍得很好。我的意思是，可能是因为马特·索恩在拍摄，但它确实拍得很好。不过我要说的是，它还缺了一样东西。什么？我觉得一部优秀的恐怖片要有创意的杀戮。哦。而在这一部里，我们看到的基本上是同样的杀戮一次又一次地上演。基本上都是同一个血手印顺着墙壁流下来。好吧，那可能已经是他们能负担得起的全部特效了。而且，因为他们杀的人并不是电影里的人。所以他们实际上能做的，他们得到的就只是某人尖叫一声然后
bloody handprint down the wall. Sure, sure. Like Angela Martin is not going to participate. She's like done. Exactly. Right. But honestly, I felt like it was really pretty good for a homemade horror film. A plus for homemade horror film.
一个血手印顺着墙壁流下来。确实，确实。就像安吉拉·马丁是不会参与的。她直接不干了。没错。对的。但老实说，我觉得对于一部家庭自制恐怖片来说，这真的相当不错。给家庭自制恐怖片打A加。
I thought it was great. Well, well done, Kelly Hannon, Jonathan Hughes, and Mary Wall. Great writing. And great directing Mindy. Yes. So, lady, two thumbs up then? I would give it two thumbs up. I would.
我觉得太棒了。好啦，干得好，凯利·汉农、乔纳森·休斯和玛丽·沃尔。编剧太棒了。导演明迪也很棒。是的。所以，各位，那就是给两个大拇指囉？我会给它两个大拇指。我会的。
But, you know, that is for the circumstances that this film is made. I did think maybe I could give a list of my favorite horror films that are like a real big thumbs up for me. Okay. Just because, you know, I do love them. I'm very curious. Okay. Well, I already mentioned that there are certain subgenres of horror that are not my thing. Like, I am not a fan of the supernatural horror or The Haunted House.
但是，你知道，那是针对这部电影拍摄的特定环境而言的。我想也许我可以列出我最喜欢的恐怖片清单，那些对我来说真正竖起大拇指的电影。好的。只是因为，你知道的，我是真的很喜欢它们。我非常好奇。好的。好吧，我之前已经提到过，某些恐怖片的子类型不是我的菜。比如，我不喜欢超自然恐怖片或鬼屋。
We talked about that. But I also do not love torture horror. Oh, no, no. I don't want to see any of that. Those are movies like Saw or Hostel. No, thank you. Those are torture horror. No, no.
我们讨论过这个。但我也非常不喜欢折磨恐怖片。哦，不，不。我不想看任何那种东西。那些就像是《电锯惊魂》或《客栈》之类的电影。不用了，谢谢。那些都是折磨恐怖片。不，不。
And I've seen them. I saw the first Saw. I saw the first Hostel. They were too much for me. I also don't usually go for Monster Horror, which, Which is what the third floor is. But isn't that also the assignment you gave me? No.
而且我都看过了。我看过第一部《电锯惊魂》。我看过第一部《客栈》。它们对我来说太过分了。我通常也不喜欢怪物恐怖片，也就是——也就是《三楼》这种类型。但那不也是你给我布置的任务吗？不对。
That is not necessarily monster horror. I think maybe it is, but I'll get to that. True, just like solid monster horror would be like Texas Chainsaw Massacre, Halloween, Friday the 13th, where there's like a masked killer on the loose. Okay. Like a type of just monster after you. Okay. However, I love zombies.
那不一定是怪物恐怖片。我觉得也许它是，但我等会儿会讲到。没错，纯正的怪物恐怖片就像是《德州电锯杀人狂》、《月光光心慌慌》、《十三号星期五》，里面有一个戴面具的杀手在四处游荡。好的。就像某种怪物追着你不放。好的。不过，我喜欢丧尸片。
love, I think that's a kind of monster, but for whatever reason, that one makes the list for me. I also mostly love, my favorite, my favorite is psychological horror and paranoia horror. And I think that is what the thing is. The thing definitely has monstery elements, but it's mostly paranoia horror, and that is my favorite genre. So do you like the movie What Lies Beneath? because I think that's, like, very scary. Do I know that movie?
我喜欢，我觉得那也算是一种怪物，但不管出于什么原因，这一类能进入我的清单。我主要还是最喜欢，我最喜欢的，是心理恐怖片和偏执狂恐怖片。我觉得《怪形》就是这种类型。《怪形》确实有怪物的元素，但它主要是偏执狂恐怖片，那是我最喜欢的类型。那你喜欢电影《谎言背后》吗？因为我觉得那部电影，非常吓人。我知道那部电影吗？
What Lies Beneath? Michelle Pfeiffer. Yeah. Yeah, it's great. It's really good. Okay, well, I will watch it immediately. Crap out of me. Okay.
《谎言背后》？米歇尔·菲佛演的。对。对，那部很棒。真的很棒。好的，那我马上就看。吓死我了。好的。
I watched it years ago not really realizing that it was a scary movie, and it's terrifying. I cannot wait. Do you agree? Yeah, it stands up. Oh, I can't wait. Okay. This is so exciting. I didn't think I would be giving you a suggestion.
我多年前看的时候并没有意识到这是一部恐怖电影，它太可怕了。我等不及了。你同意吗？对，它经得起时间的考验。哦，我等不及了。好的。这太令人兴奋了。我没想到我能给你提个建议。
What a gift. Okay, you'll have to let me know. But, like, paranoia horror would be like invasion of the body snatchers. Ooh, ugh. I love the Donald Sutherland invasion of the body snatchers. No, thank you. I love Stapford wives. Oh, I haven't seen that.
真是个大礼。好吧，你到时候得告诉我。不过，偏执狂恐怖片就像是《人体异形》。哦，呃。我超爱唐纳德·萨瑟兰主演的《人体异形》。不用了，谢谢。我爱《斯特普福的妻子们》。哦，我没看过那个。
So here is my list of 10 favorite horror movies for all y'all out there who might want to partake. But before I give this list, full disclosure, I have not seen the Babadook or Midsummer. I don't know what that means. Have you seen the Babadook? I have. I think you would like Babadook. I don't think you would like Midsummer. Babadook is great.
所以这是我列出的10部最喜欢的恐怖片清单，献给所有想要尝试一下的观众。但在我给出这份清单之前，坦白说，我没看过《巴巴杜》或《仲夏夜惊魂》。我不知道那是什么意思。你看过《巴巴杜》吗？我看过。我觉得你会喜欢《巴巴杜》的。我觉得你不会喜欢《仲夏夜惊魂》。《巴巴杜》很棒。
Highly recommend. I need to watch it. Yes. Yeah, especially based on your parameters of what you like in horror movies. I think you'll like it a lot. Okay. But it has a kid in it. And another thing that sometimes scares me is when a child's trying to kill their parents.
强烈推荐。我得去看看。是的。是的，尤其是根据你对恐怖片喜好的标准。我觉得你会很喜欢它。好的。但里面有小孩。另一个有时候会吓到我的点是，当一个小孩试图杀死他们的父母时。
Well, you'll see. Okay. Here we go, Angela. Don't watch this movie, but it is by Peter Jackson, who is, you know, Lord of the Rings. I know. He made a horror film. One of his first films is a comedy. horror film called Dead Alive.
嗯，你看过就知道了。好的。我们开始吧，安吉拉。别看这部电影，但它是彼得·杰克逊拍的，你知道的，就是《指环王》的导演。我知道。他拍过一部恐怖片。他早期的一部电影是一部喜剧恐怖片，叫《群尸玩过界》。
It is... Is it zombies? Kind of. It's people get infected. It is the goryest... No, thank you. Movie I've ever seen until this year's movie
它是……是丧尸片吗？算吧。人们被感染了。它是我看过的最血腥的……不用了，谢谢。我看过的电影，直到今年由
with Demi Moore. The substance. The substance. Yeah, no, I didn't see that. When I saw the substance, I was like, there we go. You've taken the crown from dead alive. Something I thought could never happen.
黛米·摩尔主演的电影出现。——《某种物质》。《某种物质》。对，不，我没看过。当我看到《某种物质》时，我想，行吧。你已经把《群尸玩过界》的王冠夺走了。我以为这永远不会发生的事情发生了。
Okay, number two on my list is Final Destination 2. That's the one with the truck. That's the one with the truck, Sam. The first one is the plane. The second one is the truck. I have seen none of them. Don't drive on a highway again
好的，我清单上的第二部是《死神来了2》。就是有卡车的那部。就是有卡车的那部，萨姆。第一部是飞机。第二部是卡车。这些我都没看过。看完《死神来了2》之后
after you've seen Final Destination 2. Number three, I put this on here. I saw it a long time ago, and it was a favorite of mine for a long time, but I haven't been able to get myself to rewatch it, which is Cabin Fever by Eli Roth. Cabin Fever is good. It's great. It's great.
千万别再上高速公路开车了。第三部，我把这个放进来了。我很久以前看过的，很长一段时间里它都是我的最爱，但我一直没法说服自己再去重温它，那就是伊莱·罗斯的《尸骨无存》。《尸骨无存》很不错。它很棒。它很棒。
Okay, number four, the dissent. Oh, thumbs up from Cassie. Cassie's out of her chair standing up. Yes. Angela, it's all women. It's all women, spalunkers. They go in a cave. Yeah, no, thank you.
好的，第四部，《黑暗侵袭》。哦，来自凯西的赞许。凯西从椅子上站起来了。耶。安吉拉，里面全都是女性。全都是女探洞专家。她们进了一个洞穴。对，不用了，谢谢。
I don't want to be trapped underground with anyone. It is an amazing horror movie, and it has this underlining theme of, like, dealing with grief. One of the women has had something happened in her life, and they go spulunking to kind of, like, help her through this difficult time in her life. and there is stuff in the cave. Yeah, well, yeah. It's very orc-like, lady. No, thank you. Imagine orcs in a cave.
我可不想跟任何人一起被困在地下。这是一部了不起的恐怖电影，它有一个关于应对悲伤的潜台词。其中一个女人的生活中发生了某些事情，她们去探洞是为了帮她度过生命中的这个艰难时期。而洞穴里有东西。好吧，确实。非常像兽人，各位。不用了，谢谢。想象一下洞穴里的兽人。
No, thank you. Okay, number five is It Follows. I don't like anything called It. Oh, you would like It Follows. I think you would like It Follows. I don't think so. It Follows also has a great theme about women and what would you say? The perils of misogyny.
不用了，谢谢。好的，第五部是《它在身后》。我不喜欢任何名字叫《它》的东西。哦，你会喜欢《它在身后》的。我觉得你会喜欢《它在身后》的。我不这么觉得。《它在身后》还有一个很棒的主题，关于女性以及——你会怎么说？厌女症的危害。
Original sin, I guess. Yeah. It's great. Number six is David Cronidberg's The Fly. I have seen the fly. Similar to the thing, I think. Yeah. I saw that like in college and like I look at flies differently now. How can you not? How can you not? It changes you forever. It does.
原罪吧，我猜。是的。它很棒。第六部，大卫·柯南伯格的《变蝇人》。我看过《变蝇人》。我觉得跟《怪形》有点像。对。我上大学时看的，现在我对苍蝇的看法都不一样了。你怎么可能不呢？你怎么可能不呢？它永远改变了你。确实如此。
Okay. Number seven, George Romero's Dawn of the Dead. The original Dawn of the Dead. Not the Brad Pitt one. Brad Pitt isn't in any of the Dawn of the Dead. No, he's in a zombie movie. Thank you. thank you. Yes. The remake of Dawn of the Dead is also very good. Yeah, it's all zombies. I'm not doing it. Number eight is a nightmare on Elm Street part three. This is my exception to not loving monster horror. I actually love Freddie Krueger because there is a paranoia element with not being able to sleep and people not believing you that someone's attacking you in your dreams. In high school, all of my friends got together and they made me watch Nightmare on Elm Street. I hated it. I hated it. I
好的。第七部，乔治·罗梅罗的《活死人黎明》。原版的《活死人黎明》。不是布拉德·皮特演的那部。布拉德·皮特才没演过任何一部《活死人黎明》。不，他演的是丧尸片。谢谢。谢谢。是的。《活死人黎明》的重制版也非常好看。对，全都是丧尸。我不看。第八部是《猛鬼街3》。这是我对“不爱怪物恐怖片”这一原则的例外。我其实很喜欢弗莱迪·克鲁格，因为其中包含偏执狂元素，比如无法入睡，以及别人不相信你在梦中遭到袭击。在高中时，我所有的朋友聚在一起，逼着我看《猛鬼街》。我讨厌它。我讨厌它。我
hated it. Well, number three is the one where she actually gets put like in an insane asylum and then like they're drugging her to go to sleep. And so she like gets super stuck in her dreams and Freddie Krueger. It's so good. Number nine, another paranoia horror, the faculty by Robert Rodriguez. That's, um, what's his name? He's having a resurgence right now. Josh Hartnett. Yes, that's right. Sure is. He's so good. Elijah Wood's in that too. Mm-hmm. I think so. Angela, how would you be with like a comedic like Sean of the Dead? I watch Sean of the Dead. Okay.
讨厌它。好吧，第三部是她实际上被关进精神病院，然后他们给她下药让她睡觉。所以她就像是超级深陷在梦境中，还有弗莱迪·克鲁格。太棒了。第九部，又一部偏执狂恐怖片，罗伯特·罗德里格兹的《老师不是人》。那是，嗯，叫什么来着？他现在正卷土重来。乔什·哈奈特。对，没错。确实如此。他太棒了。伊利亚·伍德也演了那个。嗯哼。我想是的。安吉拉，你看喜剧风格的《僵尸肖恩》感觉会怎么样？我看过《僵尸肖恩》。好的。
Yeah. And that? It was okay. I didn't like the zombie part. Okay. Fair enough. All right. And then finally on my list, and I'm saying it 10th, but it might be my number one is John Carpenter's the thing.
对。那部呢？还行。我不喜欢丧尸的部分。好的，有道理。好吧。最后在我的清单上，我虽然把它排在第10位，但它可能是我心中的第一名，那就是约翰·卡朋特的《怪形》。
So, Angela, I am turning it over to you. I cannot wait to hear your assessment. And you saw, I just want you to realize, of the 10 movies that I just listed, I really, I really picked the one that I thought you would actually like. Well, I really appreciate that. I really do, because all of those that you listed prior sounded horrible, and I'm thankful I want you to know that those were the other choices. Yeah.
所以，安吉拉，现在交给你了。我等不及要听你的评价了。而且你看，我只想让你意识到，在我刚列出的10部电影中，我真的、真的挑了一部我认为你实际上会喜欢的。好吧，我真的很感激。我真的非常感激，因为你之前列出的那些听起来都太可怕了，我庆幸——我想让你知道那些只是备选项。没错。
Well, you know what? In rewatching the third floor and all of these behind the scenes interviews, I did discover that I'm not the only the office cast member that doesn't like horror movies. Okay. Here's what Mindy and BJ had to say about the genre. I actually feel very uncomfortable in horror movies. I'm not a horror fan. I'm not a horror guy.
好吧，你知道吗？在重温《三楼》和所有这些幕后采访时，我确实发现我不是唯一一个不喜欢恐怖片的办公室演员。好吧。以下是明迪和比尔对这个类型的看法。我其实在恐怖片里感到非常不舒服。我不是恐怖片迷。我不是恐怖片粉丝。
I can't even say the word horror. It sounds like something else when horror. So I have good company, but I did watch the thing. And lady, I videoed myself so I could see and play back my honest. reactions to watching it. You videoed yourself? I videoed myself watching it. I watched it during the day in the afternoon because I didn't want to get scared. And I have all these videos of me watching it. Oh my gosh. And reacting in real time. And here are some of my very first reactions. I am quoting myself. I transcribed the video. Okay. Because to play it would be 24 minutes. And I thought I can't play 24
我甚至说不出“恐怖（horror）”这个词。当说horror时，听起来像别的什么。所以我有很多同伴，但我确实看了《怪形》。而且各位，我把我自己录了下来，这样我就可以看到并回放我观看时的真实反应。你把自己录下来了？我录下了自己看电影的过程。我是白天在下午看的，因为我不想被吓到。我存了所有我看的视频。天哪。而且是实时反应。以下是我最初的一些反应。我在引用我自己的话。我把视频转录成文字了。好吧。因为如果播放的话得24分钟。我想我不能播放24
minutes of me reacting. Okay. So I will share with you my first reactions to this movie. Okay. All right. I cannot wait to hear these. Sam, Cassie, Jenna. And the thing is, I have the whole video, so I can't share part of it in stories, maybe. Here it is. First of all, I should tell you that this movie has a very slow build. Mm-hmm. And I was so invested that I ended up watching the whole movie. Oh my God, my ears. Oh, my God! Oh, God. My ears of my ears.
分钟我自己的反应。好吧。所以我将与你们分享我对这部电影的第一反应。好吧。好的，我等不及要听这些了。萨姆，凯西，珍娜。关键是，我有整个视频，所以我可能不能在快拍里分享一部分。这里是。首先，我应该告诉你们，这部电影的铺垫非常慢。嗯哼。而我太投入了，以至于我最后把整部电影都看完了。哦，天哪，我的耳朵。哦，天哪！哦，天哪。我的耳朵，我的耳朵。
Okay, that was such a great reaction, Jenna. Oh, my God. You watched the whole thing? I watched the whole thing. What? You watched it all? But it is, like, I had you cut off at, like, the most cliffhangery spot. You did.
好的，那反应太棒了，珍娜。哦，天哪。你把整部都看完了？我把整部都看完了。什么？你全都看了？但它就像是，我让你在最悬疑的地方停下了。你确实这么做了。
But with enough time to reveal the first, like, monstery gross thing. Okay. So here were my. first reaction. I was just going to ask you, because you did text me and you said I might need to watch a little further. And I was just wondering if you got to the dogs. That's all. I was like, I wonder if I can't believe she didn't turn it off after the dogs. Okay. Okay. Like I said, I started to just record myself watching it for the first time. And I ultimately just hit stop because I didn't even want the distraction of myself watching yourself. Yeah. And my periphery.
但留出了足够的时间来揭晓第一个怪诞恶心的东西。好吧，所以这是我的第一反应。我正想问你，因为你确实发信息给我说我可能需要再多看一点。我只是想知道你有没有看到狗的那一段。就这样。我当时想，天哪，我不敢相信她在狗出现后竟然没有关掉。好的。好的。就像我说的，我开始只是录下自己第一次观看的过程。最后我直接按了停止，因为我甚至不想分心去看自己看视频的样子。是的。在我的余光里。
I just was so invested in the movie. I just wanted to be an audience member. It's a good plot. It's a really good plot. It's a simple plot. Here are my first reactions. And now I am quoting myself, creepy music. Just film titles and creepy music.
我太投入这部电影了。我只想当个观众。剧情很好。剧情真的很好。剧情很简单。以下是我的第一反应。现在我正在引用我自己的话，诡异的音乐。只有片名和诡异的音乐。
Yeah. Still film titles and creepy music. It goes in a while. Oh, it's a starry night. Something's flying in the sky. Oh, it's a spaceship. It's like burning through the atmosphere. Now it says, the thing.
是的。还是片名和诡异的音乐。持续了一会儿。哦，是个星空之夜。有什么东西在天空中飞。哦，是个飞船。就像在撕裂大气层燃烧。现在上面写着，《怪形》。
And there's like lightning. The screen now says Antarctica, 1982. It looks really cold. So cold. So cold. There's a helicopter. They're getting lower. There's a guy like leaning out of it with binocular things.
还有闪电。屏幕现在显示，南极洲，1982年。看起来真冷。好冷。好冷。有一架直升机。他们越飞越低。有个家伙正探出半个身子拿着双筒望远镜似的东西。
Oh, there's a dog. I think it's a husky. It might be a wolf. I can't tell. It's running like crazy. Running, running, running. The dog just looked right at the helicopter. And now it's running.
哦，有一只狗。我觉得是一只哈士奇。也可能是一只狼。我分不清。它在疯狂地奔跑。跑，跑，跑。那只狗正好朝直升机看了一眼。现在它在跑。
Oh, no. They're going to shoot it? Why? I am so mad. at this helicopter right now. Run, dog! Jenna? I'm going to be so mad if they kill this dog. Oh, wait, there's a sign. United States National Science Institute Station 4. Oh, there's a lot of dudes. There's a ping pong table. They're making whiskey. Oh, they're drinking whiskey. Oh, it's Kurt Russell. He's playing chess like on an old-timey computer. Wait a second. This computer has a
哦，不。他们要开枪打它吗？为什么？我现在对这架直升机太生气了。跑啊，狗！珍娜？如果他们杀了这只狗，我会气死的。哦，等等，有个牌子。美国国家科学研究所4号站。哦，有好多帅哥。有个乒乓球桌。他们在酿威士忌。哦，他们在喝威士忌。哦，那是库尔特·拉塞尔。他正在一台老式电脑上玩国际象棋。等一下。这台电脑的声音
really sexy voice. She's like, my move to Rook 3. Kurt is very scruffy. I like it. Oh, he lost. And he's so mad. He's like pouring whiskey into the computer. He fried it. Hey, there's a guy on roller skates. There's a guy on roller skates. And then I just really freak out because I'm like, now the helicopter's circling back. Now they're firing at the dog. What is wrong? Then he gets out of the helicopter. And then he like throws a grenade. But by accident, I think he throws it backwards and he burns up his own helicopter. blows up his friend and his whole helicopter. Yeah. What was the first time you yelled out loud at the screen? Oh. When they were shooting at the dog?
太性感了。她说，我的移动是车到3列。库尔特胡子拉碴的。我喜欢。哦，他输了。他气坏了。他把威士忌倒进电脑里。他把电脑烧毁了。嘿，有个家伙在玩轮滑。有个家伙在玩轮滑。然后我真的吓坏了，因为我想，现在直升机盘旋回来了。现在他们朝狗开枪了。到底怎么回事？然后他从直升机里出来。接着他好像扔了一颗手榴弹。但我想他失误把它往后扔了，结果炸毁了自己的直升机。炸死了他的朋友和整架直升机。对。你第一次对着屏幕大喊大叫是在什么时候？哦。当他们向狗开枪的时候？
Yes. I have it. I have it on video. Oh, there's a dog. There's a husky. He's running, running, running. He's looking at the helicopter. And now he's running away from the helicopter.
是的。我有记录。我有视频记录。哦，有一只狗。有一只哈士奇。他在跑，跑，跑。他看着直升机。现在他正从直升机旁边跑开。
And the helicopter's like coming in. Anyway, it's running. Oh, no, they're going to shoot it? Why? You can't shoot the dog? Anyway, okay, so what we learn is this helicopter, they're speaking Norwegian. Yep. And they, like, are trying to shoot the dog.
直升机正在靠近。总之，他在跑。哦，不，他们要开枪打它吗？为什么？你们不能对狗开枪！总之，好吧，所以我们了解到，这架直升机上的人在说挪威语。是的。他们试图向狗开枪。
Right. One of the American guys shoots the Norwegian guy because he's shooting at the dog, but he ends up shooting one of their dudes in the leg. Yeah, I mean, all the Americans know, these American scientists in Antarctica, all they know is that a helicopter is landed. It is blown up. Someone has left the helicopter and is shooting. at them. And so they kill the guy, and then the lone survivor is this dog that they then adopt. That they bring into their science station in Antarctica. But this one guy is a doctor, and he's like, hey, I want to know, like, where they, what's going on with them? Maybe they've gone
对。其中一个美国人开枪打死了那个挪威人，因为他在向狗开枪，但他最后却打中了他们自己人的腿。对啊，我的意思是，所有的美国人都知道，这些在南极洲的美国科学家，他们只知道一架直升机降落了。它爆炸了。有人从直升机里出来并在向
stir crazy. Like, let's go see. There's a storm coming. That's never a good thing. And then the guy, Kurt Russell, plays Mack. He wears like a... By the way, you're welcome. I, only gave you the Pedro Pascal of his time. Oh, he's... Mr. Kurt Russell. He's scruffy and super hot. And his voice is amazing. He's Mac.
他们开枪。所以他们杀了那个人，而唯一的幸存者就是这只狗，然后他们收养了它。把它带到了他们在南极洲的科学站。但其中一个人是医生，他就像是，嘿，我想知道，他们那儿到底是怎么回事，发生了什么？也许他们都被
He's Mac with his sideways cowboy hat. He drinks so much whiskey. Everybody drinks. Everyone's drinking. They're drinking constantly. I don't understand how they ever get any work done at this facility. Okay. Whatever they're supposed to be doing there.
逼疯了。去看看吧。暴风雨要来了。这绝不是什么好兆头。然后那个家伙，库尔特·拉塞尔扮演的麦克。他戴着一顶……顺便说一句，不客气。我，只给了你那个时代佩德罗·帕斯卡。哦，他是……库尔特·拉塞尔先生。他胡子拉碴，超级性感。他的声音太棒了。他是麦克。
Mac and this doctor, they go to the Norwegian station, right? Yeah, to see, like, what happened. It has been blown to bits. It's charred. It's frozen. Yep. And they find this, like, grossest looking thing. Thing. It's so gross.
他是戴着歪斜牛仔帽的麦克。他喝了好多威士忌。每个人都在喝。每个人都在喝。他们一直在喝酒。我真不明白他们在这个设施里是怎么完成任何工作的。好吧。不管他们在那儿应该做什么。
It looks like it has two heads and multiple appendages. And the doctor's like, we're taking it back with us. I'm like, what? That was the second time I yelled, Sam. But hold on. It's not going to matter if they brought that thing back. Because the dog is there. The dog is already there.
麦克和这个医生，他们去了挪威人的基地，对吧？对，去看看发生了什么。那里已经被炸成碎片了。焦黑一片。冻得结结实实的。对。他们找到了这个，看起来最恶心的东西。怪形。太恶心了。
You don't know that. You don't know that. that. So right now, I'm thinking, you're idiots. Why would you take this weird thing back? And then immediately they get it back and they start an autopsy on it. It's so disgusting. That's where I stopped it for you. I thought maybe that's all Angela can stand. No, I was in. I was in because I'm like, this thing on this autopsy table is going to kill them all. But what I didn't know is the dog I had been rooting for all along. Yep. Had been mutated by the thing.
它看起来像是有两个头和许多附肢。医生说，我们要把它带回我们那儿。我说，什么？那是第二次我大喊大叫，萨姆。但等等。如果他们把那个怪形带回来，那就麻烦了。因为狗在那儿。狗已经在那里了。
Yep. And it splits in half in a dog kennel and all these like things come flying out of it. And it like, it gets all the other dogs. Yeah. And part of it you see wiggles out. Yep. And I'm like, oh, that's going to. This is a perfect description of the movie The Thing.
你不知道。你根本不知道。所以当时我想，你们这些白痴。为什么要把这个奇怪的东西带回来？然后他们一把它带回去，就开始对它进行尸检。太令人作呕了。我在那儿给你按了暂停。我想这也许就是安吉拉能忍受的极限了。不，我完全入戏了。我完全入戏了，因为我想，解剖台上的这个东西会把他们全杀光。但我不知道的是，我一直支持的那只狗。是的。已经被怪形变异了。
This is perfect. And then immediately I'm like, they're all dead. We know this now. They're all going to die. Listen, we don't have to describe the whole movie to you, but it is so good. It's very good. And it goes on and on. And there is such paranoia because they don't know who's infected and who's not.
是的，它在狗窝里裂成两半，所有这些像怪物一样的东西从里面飞奔出来。它袭击了所有的狗。是的。你能看到一部分蠕动着逃走了。是的。然后我想，哦，那要——对电影《怪形》的完美描述。
It's very hard to tell who's infected. Also, they're not great at communicating with one another. And they separate. I'm always like, why, when they're like, you two go there. I'm like, they're dead. Here's the other thing about this movie that is so amazing. It's from so long ago. There is no CGI crepull.
这太完美了。紧接着我就想，他们都死定了。我们现在知道了。他们全都会死。听着，我们不需要向你剧透整部电影，但它真的太棒了。非常棒。而且剧情不断推进。充满了偏执，因为他们不知道谁被感染了，谁没有。
in this movie. It's not computer-generated. It is all practical effects. I have to give a shout out to the special effects guy. It's Rob Botton, and he was only 22 years old when he did the effects for this movie. He also did the effects for Total Recall. You know that scene in Total Recall where the lady's face splits open? Oh, yeah. That's him. But the practical effects in this are nuts. How about the scene where I'm sure you didn't see it coming? I don't know how you made it through it when they go to do the like the kjunk of the CPR
很难分辨谁被感染了。而且，他们彼此之间的沟通并不好。他们分散开来。我总是想，为什么当他们说，你们两个去那边时。我就想，他们死定了。关于这部电影还有一件非常了不起的事情。这是很久以前拍的。里面没有任何电脑生成的怪物杂碎。
on the guy who like has the heart attack and they do the kajunk yeah and then you know what happens his whole he explodes his whole chest opens up and like a giant mouth
在这部电影里。不是电脑生成的。全都是实景特效。我必须向特效师致敬。他是罗伯·博廷，他做这部电影的特效时只有22岁。他还为《全面回忆》做过特效。你知道《全面回忆》里那个女人的脸裂开的那个场景吗？哦，对。就是他。但这里的实景特效太疯狂了。还有那个场景，我确信你绝对猜不到？我不知道你是怎么熬过去的，当他们去对那个心脏病发作的家伙进行心肺复苏时，他们做那个动作，然后你知道发生了什么吗？他的整个人——他爆炸了，他的整个胸腔裂开，就像一个巨大的嘴巴
like eats off the hands of the person who was doing the kajunk yes yeah yeah no spoiler it was listen it doesn't matter that I've told you it's still gonna fucking kick your ass when you see it. Listen, that was disgusting, but honestly, the part when the dog exploded and then all the
把正在做心肺复苏的那个人的双手给吃掉了，是的。对，对。没有剧透，听着，不管我有没有告诉你，当你看到它时，它依然会狠狠地踢你的屁股。听着，那太恶心了，但老实说，当那只狗爆炸然后所有小怪物从里面涌出来的时候，对我的打击更大。一旦我看到了那个，无论那个怪形接下来还要对大家做什么，我都能承受了。是的。它吸收其他人的方式太恶心了。那个玩轮滑的家伙总是不停地发现别人的衣服被撕破了。然后他说，嘿，伙计们，清理工作做得好一点。我想，他们死定了。他们都死定了。而且我真的很喜欢这部电影的一点是，导演花了多少时间和耐心。他太有耐心了。他没有仓促处理任何时刻，我真的很喜欢这一点。然后我觉得结局真是太棒了。太棒了。它没有给出一个圆满的结局。
little things came out of them was worse for me. Once I had seen that, I could handle whatever else that thing had coming for everyone. Yeah. The way it does absorb other people is so disgusting. And the one guy on roller skates keeps like finding people's clothes ripped. And he's like, hey, you guys, do a better job cleaning up. I'm like, they're dead. They are dead. And what I also really liked about this movie was just how much time and patience the director had. He was so patient. He didn't rush any moment. And I really liked that. And then I thought the ending was just so good. So good. It does not wrap up with a bow.
我真的很喜欢。我真的很喜欢。我太高兴了，各位。演员表现太棒了。编剧太棒了。它还带有一点生存主义的色彩。我对那些以荒野或寒冷为背景的故事一直很感兴趣，你知道的。我喜欢这种孤立无援的感觉，你知道的。哦，是的，冬天刚刚降临。所以他们，他们彻底完蛋了。对。对。对。哦，我没分享的一个评论是我第一次看到那个巨大的冰块时。哦，对。我说，巨大的冰块里可能封存着某种弗兰肯斯坦式的怪物。不好。是的。不过话说回来，好电影。好电影。我很喜欢。谢谢你推荐它，没让我看那些对我来说过于刺激的其他电影。
And I really liked it. I really liked it. I'm so glad, lady. It's a great person. performances. It's great writing. It also has a little bit of like that survivalist aspect to it. I'm always interested in things that are set in wilderness or like the cold, you know. I love that it's just this, the isolation of these people, you know. Oh, yeah, winter has just set in. So they're, they're just screwed. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Oh, one of the comments I didn't share was the very first time I saw the giant ice cube. Oh, yeah. I was like, giant ice cube probably holds some kind of Frankenstein thing. Not good. Yeah. But yeah, great movie. Great movie. I liked it. Thank you for suggesting it and not making me watch those other ones that would have been too much for me.
好吧，我只能说，各位，既然我们知道我已经看过《指环王》并且见过兽人了。是的。我不确定这部电影里还有多少比《指环王》里诞生的兽人更血腥或更恐怖的场景。哦，不，太恶心了。它们那种滑落在黏糊糊的、像巨型泥潭里的样子。不，太恶心了。到底是什么让你不喜欢恐怖片？因为肯定不是因为暴力和血腥。
Well, I just have to say, lady, now that we know that I have watched Lord of the Rings and I've seen the orcs. Yes. I'm not sure there was much more about this movie that was more gory or terrifying than like an orc being born in Lord of the Rings. Oh, no, it's disgusting. The way they kind of plop down in that gelatinous, like, giant mud hole. No, it's so gross. What is it about horror movies you don't like? Because it can't be the violence and the gore.
因为你经常看非常暴力的东西。《毒枭》、《权力的游戏》、《指环王》。那到底是什么让你不喜欢？我不喜欢，喜欢，喜欢，悬念。啊，我不喜欢……悬念带来的压力。我不喜欢等待突发惊吓。直接进入正题吧。所以像这样，这对我来说很合理，因为《权力的游戏》中的很多暴力，都是关于复仇、战争或某种战斗。你可以接受战斗。对，当我看到战斗场景时，我想，好吧，他们是来打仗的。对。要大开杀戒了。对。但如果我只是
Because you watch very violent stuff all the time. Narcos, Game of Thrones, Lord of the Rings. Like, what is it that you don't like? I don't like, like, like, suspense. Ah, I don't like... The stress of suspense. I don't like waiting for the jump scare. Just get to it. Okay. So like, and that makes sense to me because a lot of the violence in Game of Thrones, it's like revenge or war or something, battle. You can do battle. Yeah, when I see a battle scene, I'm like, okay, they're here to fight. Right. It's going to go down. Right. But if I'm just walking
深夜走进厨房，给自己倒杯牛奶，当然。我打开冰箱，然后我打开冰箱，然后我关上。结果那里站着一个人。我不喜欢这样。我懂。而且我知道它要来了。我知道它要来了。还有，其中一件事，就在这部电影的开头，莫名其妙地出现了一个大汽油罐的特写镜头。我就想，哦，他们待会儿会用到那个的。现在我开始等了。我在等。他们什么时候需要汽油？对。对。好吧，我的心好高兴。谢谢你送我观看这部电影的礼物，也谢谢你喜欢它。我不知道你会不会——我的意思是，我本来没指望你会喜欢，但我太高兴你喜欢了。它真的拍得很棒。真的拍得很棒。好了，各位。看吧。珍娜，我们在我们的友谊中，一直在鼓励彼此成长并体验新事物。今年真的很令人兴奋。我们都五十岁了。看看我们。我们做到了。这应该向任何人证明。体验新鲜事物永远都不会太晚。
into my kitchen late at night, pour myself a glass of milk, sure. I open the fridge and then I open the fridge and And then I shut it. And there's a guy there. I don't like it. I get it. And I know it's coming. I know it's coming. Also, one of the things, like right at the beginning of this movie, there's this for no reason an establishing shot of a big tank of gasoline. I'm like, oh, they're going to need that. Like, now I'm waiting. I'm waiting. What do they need the gasoline for? Yeah. Yeah. All right. Well, my heart is so happy. Thank you for the gift of watching this movie and for liking it. I did not know if you. I mean, I just didn't expect you to like it, but I'm so glad you did. It's really well done. It's really well done. There you go, you guys. Look at that. Jenna, we're just like, in our friendship, we're just encouraging each other to grow and experience new things. This is a really exciting year. We're in our 50s. And look at us. We're doing this. This should prove to anyone. It's never too late to experience something new.
好了，谢谢大家今天加入我们，我喜欢这期网络短剧，我也喜欢今天的节目。是的，谢谢埃莉·坎珀总是回复我那些疯狂的短信。我们希望大家度过美好的一周，我们下期见。感谢收听“办公室女士”，“办公室女士”是Audyssey的一档节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的执行制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗，副制作人是艾恩斯利·布比科。Audyssey的执行制作人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。“办公室女士”由比尔·舒尔茨进行混音和母带制作。
all right well thank you everyone for joining us today i love this webisode and i love today's episode yeah and thank you to ellie kimper for always answering my crazy text messages and we hope you guys have a great week we'll see you next time thank you for listening to office ladies office ladies is a presentation of odyssey and is produced by jennifer and angela kenzie Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbico. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz.
我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Ruppertree》。谢谢。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。
Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的主题曲是Creed Bratton的《Ruppertree》。谢谢。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。